buenos días hoy es un día muy especial
en este momento se enciende la señal de
france 24 en español el momento de la
cultura en france 24 y santiago porque
este mes se estrenó durante el festival
de cine hoy comenzó bien lo decía la
segunda fecha de la fase de grupo de la
liga de campeones de europa bienvenidos
a la crónica historia de france 24
bienvenidos a reporteros de france 24
historias con profundidad algunos jefes
de estado ya han llegado aquí a lima
para la octava cumbre de las américas ha
terminado la manifestación de los
chalecos amarillos a erbol
hola bienvenidos a esta emisión especial
de inmigrantes esta es la primera
manifestación de marzo estamos muy
felices porque duplicamos nuestro tiempo
de programación al aire desde este
preciso momento estaremos 12 horas al
día estamos exactamente a 12 horas de
este divorcio de la eurocámara ha votado
a favor del acuerdo de salida
materializándose así el break sheet
continuó aumentando el número de muertos
por el coronavirus procedente de hojas
de que empezó la epidemia y hasta hoy
aquí hay muchas medidas de seguridad por
ejemplo al entrar nos miden la
temperatura y utilizan el reconocimiento
facial la decisión dramática y sin
precedentes de declarar todo el país en
cuarentena toque de queda que obliga a
todos los ciudadanos a mantenerse en sus
casas hospitales y morgues se encuentran
completamente desbordados ante la
situación de kobe 19 ahora trabajamos de
este caso nos adaptamos desde nuestros
hogares para llevarles toda la
información una semana de la mayor
catástrofe nuclear de la historia
[Música]
la victoria del candidato demócrata joe
volveremos al papá llegando a bagdad y
luego estar a su lado por cuatro años
llevándole s toda la información
internacional hoy 24 de septiembre
aumentamos nuestro compromiso con
ustedes ofreciéndoles 24 horas de
programación completamente en español
los acompaño del lunes a viernes todas
las mañanas con directo américa nuestro
nuevo programa matinal ahí los espero